as for Russell Brand I think i
profoundly disagree says don't vote
that's his whole view don't vote it's a
you know it only encourages them or
something I mean either it's funny right
it's funny but you know politics and
life and elections and jobs and the
economy it's not a joke Russell Brand's
a joke right ed Miliband hang out with
Russell Brand he's a joke this is not
funny this is about the election this is
about our future it's about jobs about
the economy is about the recovery I
haven't got time to hang out with
Russell Brand this is more important
these are real people these losers of
this election is all about don't forget
to vote however you vote it's important
don't listen to Russell Brand get out
there with your stubby pencil thank you
very much